the hardest thing for me about my weight
loss was at 14 years old going to work
at General Hospital
and they decided to put Lora on a diet
it was very hard for me as a very young
girl to be put on a diet on TV and that
made me very insecure that's how you
know my body image how it began
I have been on every diet there is every
fad crazy diet I've been in pain about
my body and my weight all my life I
tried Nutrisystem telling myself when I
saw the food and all the things that I
could eat this isn't gonna work
there is no way that I can eat all that
food and have a dessert and lose weight
I'll do it I'll do it just to prove you
wrong but you know it's not gonna work I
lost 40 pounds on Nutrisystem it's crazy
I have never been that nice to myself
with my food
I have always restricted food and and
really suffered with weight loss I am
NOT suffering here
I will never go back to those crazy
diets you can't change by thinking you
can change by doing I am walking living
proof that Nutrisystem works if it works
for me it will definitely work for you